hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 1 of on
free choice of the will one of the
topics that Augustine addresses with his
student of odious is the relationship
between the the virtues and here he has
in mind the cardinal virtues and what he
is calling the good will and there's
going to be sort of a reciprocal
relation between these two so that the
virtues play a central role in how it is
that the goodwill is configured how the
goodwill maintains itself and he tells
us at one point this very nice formula
when his student asks well what is a
goodwill he says a will by which we do
three things and one of these is to live
virtuously live in accordance with the
virtues the other two are to live
rightly which is you know largely a
synonym here for living virtuously
although we might you know parse it out
further and then he says and a will by
which we seek to reach the height of
human wisdom and wisdom is also going to
be connected with the virtues we're not
going to talk about that too much here
because we want to focus specifically
the virtues he also tells us two other
things a little bit earlier than that in
the dialogue one of these is that
whether or not we have and use the
virtues that is something that lies
within the power of the will so it's not
as if we're just naturally prudent or
brave or just there could be some
tendencies in that direction but that's
not yet having these virtues and quite
likely whatever natural impulses we
might have due to temperament could
easily be corrupted if we're not
thinking about this in terms of the will
and its function of choosing or
committing itself or if you like
prioritizing goods over each other so
whether or not we're virtuous lies
within the power of the will he also
tells us that if we're understanding
things in the proper framework we can
see that virtue is actually more
powerful than Vice and it's preferable
to its advice now you can say well in
that case why are people ever vicious
and we'll come to that in a moment first
though we need to think about what the
virtues actually are and to those who
are familiar with the cardinal virtues
from other frameworks perhaps those of
plate inist or stoic or even epicurean
discussions of the virtues these four
will be you know familiar to them they
are prudence fortitude or bravery or
courage you could say temperance or
self-control and justice so he leads his
his students through discussing what
these actually are and so let's look at
each of these in turn e says consider
whether prudence seems to you to consist
in knowledge of what to seek and avoid
so prudence or practical wisdom
is a type of practical knowledge that we
have of what it is that we ought to
choose or select or pursue and what it
is that we ought to reject or avoid or
be averse to now you could say well it
must rely on having some knowledge about
these things and that's quite true and
you know traditionally this this virtue
has been seen as the one which helps us
to get past mere rules to think
indeterminate cases
well what's actually good for me in this
situation or what's good for a human
being in general in this situation and
so how should I act and prudence is what
what does that for us so it directs us
towards the good or it chooses between
an array of goods the greater good and
tells us to pursue that fortitude or
courage or bravery fortitude oh right in
in Latin here he picks out one
particular feature instead of looking at
some other traditionally ascribed
features of that virtue he says
fortitude is the state of the soul in
which we despise all misfortunes all bad
things that happen to us and the loss of
things not resting in our power so it's
a capacity for going on for resisting
for not giving in and there's other ways
in which fortitude has been expressed as
well
temperance plays another very important
role and here he says something quite
interesting he says temperance is that
state of soul which controls and checks
desire in regard to those things which
it is shameful to desire so
traditionally the virtue of temperance
or self-control would be looked at as
applying to say sexuality and sexual
desire or the desire for food or the
desire for intoxicating substances you
know the ancients usually talked in
terms of drinking and wine but we could
think about getting high and many other
ways as well
so temperance is is what helps us to
structure our desires and when it
encounters desires that we have for
things that are shameful to desire
things that we ought not to desire like
you know not just having sex in general
but having sex with somebody we're not
supposed to or in ways that you know are
far to say public or something like that
it would say no no don't do that
it would resist that and and say maybe I
can't stop feeling that desire but I'm
not gonna give in to it or similarly
with eating you know if if you're
getting upset because the waiter brings
out your meal and it's not so perfect
that you'll leave a wonderful review on
Yelp
you're intemperate and temperance would
say hey knock that off the food is just
fine eat it up and then get out of there
and leave a tip right instead of leaving
a bunch of complaints very common sort
of commonplace scenario just as he says
what else are we to say about justice
then that is the virtue by which each
person is given their due and of odious
the student says yeah that's what I
think about justice so justice is is
what you know leads us to giving
everybody what it is that they deserve
that could be rewards or that could be
benefits in return or that could be a
fair distribution or that might also be
punishment as well if they actually
deserve it and we're the right person to
give that now he goes on and he asks the
person who has a good will are they
going to have these virtues and he says
can we suppose that a person who
actually has a good will is not endowed
with prudence who sees that this good
that is the good will should be sought
for and everything avoided which
conflicts with it so this is specifying
prudence and saying the person who
actually has a good will will realize
that they ought to more highly
prioritize or value that goodwill above
other goods fortitude as well
is going to be important he says why
should we not grant him fortitude he
cannot love and value all highly all
these things not under our control if we
do then their love through an evil will
and he's bound to resist an evil will as
the enemy of his most precious good so
when he loses these things like say you
know you're faced with a situation where
doing the right thing is going to cost
you some pleasures or some security so
desire or fear are at play the person
who actually has fortitude is gonna say
yeah I'm gonna take the good will I'm
gonna take in this case justice over
giving in to these these desires what
about temperance so he says can we
deprive him of temperance this is the
virtue that checks passion what is so
opposed to a good will is passion hence
you can understand that the person who
loves their good will resist their
passions by every means and fights
against them
therefore they are rightly said to have
temperance and now no it's no longer
just about the Honorable but it's a bit
more you could say across-the-board
right
and then finally justice he says I don't
see how such a person can lack this if
they possess and love to possess a good
will and resist what as opposed to it
you cannot wish evil to anyone it
follows that he harms no one and this
can only be the case if he gives to
everyone his due so you know we could
raise some issues here about punishment
or resisting evil you know by say
killing people but Augustine talks about
that in other places so I'm going to
answer gloss over that here so all of
these virtues are going to be present in
any person who actually has a good will
and who values and loves that goodwill
this leads us to thinking about how
these could be lost as well if you don't
use the virtues that you have we
you get into difficult situations of
temptation or forced choice or
difficulty then that would be a sign
that one doesn't value and decide to
keep that goodwill instead one decides
for some other thing and that would be
acting in a vicious way and that's a
good way to lose these virtues and to
thereby also abandon or lose that
goodwill in the process but so long as a
person decides that now having the
goodwill is what matters most to me they
will be able to develop and use and
probably enhance and you know
consolidate you might say these four
cardinal virtues which then help them to
keep the goodwill they make those tough
decisions a little less tough maybe even
into what we sometimes facetiously call
no-brainers meaning you don't have to
think that much about it because if you
see that the goodwill is what is truly
valuable and living virtuously as part
of that you're going to want to behave
in that way
and eventually it becomes a you know as
Aristotle had said so long ago second
nature so that's the relation here
between the four cardinal virtues and
the goodwill
you